welcome the best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can watch just
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go along
with this video check out the link in
the description below alright so today
is bonus day number two and we're gonna
learn how to optimize our sleep lesson 1
get an additional 30 minutes of sleep a
night take it as a challenge try to find
that space quiet your mind and get your
30 minutes of sleep and you'll see it
makes a really really big difference my
sleep habits were horrendous to say the
least
I mean I I've always had a hard time
sleeping you know I couldn't figure out
how to shut my brain off so we made the
light bulb come on is that I went out
there and played a game and I played
like crap now it's like why am i playing
like crap because I've been practicing
these same moves over and over and over
but yet I couldn't execute them properly
I was feeling sluggish I was filling
with our Jake and I knew it wasn't
because of my training because I had
trained obsessively so then I started
looking at other things and that's when
I came to the realization that a cold
you're not 21 years old anymore buddy
maybe the fact I should sleep in 2 or 3
hours a night maybe that has something
to do with the fact that you're playing
like crap and that's what I started
really evaluating those things first of
all I prioritize sleep and that means
making that means saying no to things
you want to do it's not easy there's
hard I think you noticing last night you
know shall sun-baked interviewed me the
summers go Symphony Hall and then I had
to sign books and I would have loved to
go and have dinner with her but I went
to bed and you know because if I hadn't
got if I'd gone out to dinner and hadn't
gotten my at least seven hours sleep at
I need and had to get up early to do TV
I would not be enjoying being here with
you now and I'm really enjoying it and
one person present I'm not tired and I
hate being tired more than I hate
anything from my perspective when people
ask me all the time though I lack
discipline how can I get discipline in
my life and no one wants to hear this
answer no one wants to hear just do it
the one of the first steps you can take
to impose discipline in your life is to
wake up early in the morning because
let's face it when the alarm goes off
you're you got your head on that soft
pillow it's all nice and cozy and warm
in there you do not feel like getting up
and so you doesn't even have a snooze
alarm he doesn't ever hit the snooze
engine you should not you should not
that snooze alarm is that's insane I
call that snooze alarm the dream killer
like when you put on you when you press
that snooze button you're killing your
dreams so don't touch this button now
some would say that might be a little
extreme know where people get worried
and people freak out
yeah is sleep is healthy sleep is good
for you I know that I get it and people
say you're telling people not to sleep
no I'm not telling people not to say you
do six hours every night yeah I usually
go to bed around 10:30 11:00 and I wake
up at 4:30 so I get five and a half to
six hours almost every night you know
and sometimes I tell people I I
I think sleeping is good I do it almost
every single day but but people will
freak out and say you're telling people
to be unhealthy I'm not saying that at
all I'm not you know if you need
different people are they have different
genetic needs for sleep I'm one of those
people that doesn't need much of my four
kids
my oldest daughter needs even less sleep
than I do my middle daughter sleeps more
like my wife my son somewhere in the
middle which by the way that means my
middle daughter she gets out of bed when
you get her out of bed in the morning
she likes to sleep so I'm not telling
people hey don't sleep but I am saying
put yourself on a schedule and you know
you ask why I don't sleep in if you
sleep in if I sleep on in on a Saturday
until six o'clock ooh that night I'm
gonna have more energy and instead of
going to bed at 10:30 or 11:00 I'm gonna
stay up until midnight because I got
only one extra sleep well now that next
day I'm gonna sleep in a little bit more
than all of a sudden Sunday I'm sleeping
in till 7 o'clock now Sunday night I
can't go to bed until 1 o'clock in
morning and you see where I'm going with
this I go into Monday with a lack of
sleep because I couldn't fall asleep
I just the most important thing is set a
good wakeup time that works for you
where you get enough sleep and then wake
up that time every day if you can we've
known for a very long time
only about fifty years of real research
that if you're not getting enough sleep
your cognitive abilities throughout the
day go down your creativity goes down
your stress goes up your bad
decision-making goes up and your ability
to handle conflict or life challenges
and be resilient and happy and positive
all goes to [ __ ] so what do you do how
do you get more sleep how do you finally
manage this part of your life because
look we all have a lot of expectations a
lot of demands on our lives and so at
some point we start believing the hype
out there that oh hey you can get by on
you know three four hours of sleep don't
worry about it just sleep a little less
get up a little earlier and we start
telling ourselves a big lie that we can
get away with less sleep even though we
have 50 years of science saying we can't
especially today you know there's this
popular myth that oh you know you can
take you know sleep for two hours you
know rest take a nap for thirty minutes
here and there or sleep for four hours
and nap and meditate throughout the day
to catch up and the rowdies we know
that's not possible for the vast
majority of people people say well
Brendon the Navy SEALs can do it I'm
like yes but you're not a Navy SEAL and
they hate it and they call it hell week
when they do that okay
most normal average must perform must be
awesome care about your high performance
and have to be smart people throughout
the day really must sleep seven to eight
hours a night so if you're not getting
that on consistent basis what can you do
if you want to be an effective
entrepreneur you need to be able to have
good quality sleep this is the most
important aspect of making sure that you
are running on all cylinders the quality
of your sleep matters just as much if
not more than how long you sleep and for
me as an entrepreneur with so much on my
mind all the time you know I can't have
a mattress that causes me to toss and
turn the
more rest I had the quality of sleep no
tossing and turning the comfort you know
it allows me to make better decisions
have better energy the next day just
truly be the most efficient Garrard that
I could possibly be
why do you prioritize sleep so highly
just curious of what makes you so
committed to that and the science behind
it thank you for all you do I find that
I'm slower when I'm fatigued so I find
myself drifting I have more symptoms of
what we'll call a tee a DD so that my
attention is just drift drift drifts and
then I find I'll read a sentence or
whatever and be like kind of to reread
the sentence like ten times so that was
just going whoa I'm not as efficient as
I could be and then the other is I find
it a unique form of misery there is an
additional ring of Hell that is saved
just for people who are fatigued I hate
it so much
so it's misery and I don't understand
people that live a life that is
miserable I just don't get it and then
on top of that I think you actually
accomplish less if you're fatigued so
you're putting more hours we're actually
getting less done per hour
so if being fatigued puts you at like
0.6 of what your output could be and
then being just like incredibly well
rested prioritizing that puts you at you
know it's I guess mathematically I
should be saying just one then like you
have to make up 40% of the number of
hours and waking up early just to break
even and then you put misery on top of
that so that that's my end of one
experience is that I am so deadly
efficient when I'm rested that I just
get more done so comparing those two
side-by-side I get I actually accomplish
more I've had the best coach over the
last seven years that I've known him and
that's Craig Valentine what do you think
the biggest lesson you learned from him
in the last seven eight years the
biggest lesson was to sleep at the same
time wake up at the same time seven days
a week no matter what really his sleep
is so valuable it's so important so I
rated I used to think that I here's what
I was I'm a fighter jet I would
literally walk around the house hunting
I'm a fighter jet fighter jet and
you know doesn't even come down to get
refueled they're up there getting
revealed right we've all seen the
YouTube videos yeah well the fighter jet
if they leave those afterburners on too
long they just fall out of the sky which
I know one had told me right until I
fell out of the sky I was having
essential tremors and anxiety attacks
and not realizing it and as I got better
its sleep those just went away cuz the
one discipline leads to another and to
another how you do anything is how you
do everything all right
and so that that one thing that he
taught me or I learned through him and
we'd be in Vegas we'd run a mastermind
together because now we run a mastermind
together and at 8 o'clock
he's gone buddy were you going to sleep
yeah I'm gonna by 9 or whatever matter
yeah yeah exactly he powers off 30
minutes all his electronics before so
now I do the same thing I power off I
don't go to bed and then do this yeah
powered off 30 minutes before and my
mind stops racing and the left and right
side start reconciling of the
information I took in throughout the day
versus the information I keep consuming
taking yeah right until I fall asleep
and then Lord knows what happens in my
brain right right
what time you go to bed and wake up
10:30 10:30 I'm in bed wake up at 5:30
Wow and and that's it spell no matter
what even if you're in Vegas or I'm
traveling around the world or whatever
yeah I'll adjust to that times when real
quickly and 10:30 I'm in bed 5:30 a.m. I
wake up and I go right through my
rituals the thing I treat like a job now
is not my job I love my job it's a joy
and a hobby so what I treat as a job is
sleep and breakfast is my thing right
yeah and what why is that important okay
so I wasn't sleeping right and that as
an adult with modern technology and
being responsible right I was never I
always wanted to be personally involved
in my stuff so I was not stopping and
there was always an excuse to not go of
it and even though you were going man
just get to bleed in bed
spend all night send it for kids all
about him but then I went and met asleep
scientists and started getting into it
you start realizing that sleep has the
most powerful effect on all of your body
the way you metabolize food your energy
the way you fight disease your your skin
your energy and the rhythms of those so
it's quality not quantity not no less
than six no more than nine get a good
night's sleep do you know the secret
elixir of life is sleep
everybody wants us natural everything
once you track good night's sleep for a
change
you know what you've learned in the
daytime is imprinted on your brain while
you sleep so if you're not getting a
good night's sleep you're not taking
advantage of your education my mom only
cared about two things saving and
sleeping well it's the only two things I
don't care what you're doing you're
going to bed early and you're getting a
good night's sleep your grades aren't as
important as a good night's sleep rich
why do you sleep in a tent for those
that don't know for the last two years
I've been sleeping outside in this thing
a lot of people have been asking me why
do you do that and it basically boils
down to three fundamental reasons the
first is I just sleep better in a tent
outside the second reason is that it
really has helped me connect with nature
and the outdoors and I think our primal
disposition and the third reason I've
been doing it is because fundamentally
it's a stoic practice a couple years ago
I started struggling with trying to get
a deep sleep unless I was training
SuperDuper hard I just found it
difficult to get the restfulness that my
body and my mind need and at the time
our bedroom that I share with my wife
Julie was either too cold for her or too
hot for me then I had an experience
where we as a family all slept on our
roof one night we have a flat roof and
we did it just for fun with the kids and
I had the most restful peaceful night of
sleep in recent memory being outdoors
breathing that outdoor air sleeping
under the stars is a very simple and
basic way of reconnecting with what it
means to be fundamentally human we live
in this super fast-paced culture you got
to get your hustle on you got to like
work 24 hours a day and if you're not
being productive in every moment of your
waking existence then you're wasting
time and you're falling behind and with
that comes a deep prioritization of
sleep sleep is for slackers right and
nothing could be further from the truth
I know that I can't perform a my very
best unless I get eight hours of sleep
and it's not just the amount of time
that I sleep it's the quality of that
sleep it's the caliber of that sleep it
is my opinion that everybody should be
doing everything they can to enhance
that quality of their evening hours and
I found that by sleeping in a tent it's
almost like this hack towards improving
the caliber of my sleep so that I can
show up throughout my day and excel be
totally focused be totally present have
good energy be in a good mood and all of
that derives from sleep so if you really
take the time to prioritize the quality
and the amount of time that you're
sleeping every night you will realize
quantum gains in your productivity in
your output throughout your day now I've
got a special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the best live 30 questions of
the day
it's not enough to just watch a video
like this you have to do something and
take action in your life so pull out
your worksheets and answer these
questions and if you don't have the
worksheets yet you can get them for free
by signing up for the series in the
description below here we go question
number one how much sleep do you need to
get every night number two how can you
design your schedule so what happens
consistently and number three how can
you improve the quality of your sleep
and if you're doing the best life 30
challenge with me give me a hashtag best
live 30 down the comments as well so I
can celebrate you
why do you think that entrepreneurs
sacrifice sleep over work I think a lot
of lot has to get done you know like
entrepreneurs have insane amounts of
work you're you're especially in the
early days you're you're the CEO to the
janitor this like nobody cares more than
you you may not have the budget to be
able to delegate to somebody else or you
may suck at delegating and feel like
you're the only one who has the skills
to be able to do whatever project you
can work is never done as an
entrepreneur like there's always
something there's always you always want
to grow you always you either putting
out a fire that has to get done or
you've got this great new vision of what
you want to do and you want to get it
done like your inbox is never empty
there's always something happening and
so there's always that pressure
especially if it's a financial one where
it's really on in your business before
you're able to fully support yourself
you feel like if I don't get this done I
could be out of a business in six months
and have to go get a job again so you're
hustling and fighting for that and
people know you know rationally
logically that I can't keep doing this
because I'm gonna get sick and I'm gonna
burn out and I'm gonna crash whatever
that's a hard argument when you're
feeling the crunch and feeling the pain
to kind of drive through and push so how
do you think we came up how do you think
we can I guarantee that that we don't do
that right that we don't just keep on
pushing keep on pushing keep on pushing
it because we think like one more one
more one more right like so what do you
think we can do to just you know not get
there so for me there's two sides of
that coin one is work cuz work has to
get done and I think for that you need
to set boundaries for yourself and
schedule it in like if you're married or
you know you have a girlfriend boyfriend
whatever make make time with them just
as important as time on your business
otherwise that relationships not gonna
last right so I put things in my
calendar right time with Nina
so that is an appointment that I don't
let run over because otherwise a lot of
your business can bleed into your
personal time and so you need to set
some kind of boundary on it the
exception that I make is when I'm in
flow like there are times when you are
just feeling it not not because you've
got to like do something that's gonna
have a minimal impact but just like
you're in the zone you're flowing this
then it's not every day when you're in
that zone when when I'm there I try to
stay there as long as I can I push
everything off as long as I can until I
feel like I'm not in flow anymore and I
feel I feel it's super important to do
that so I don't have an alarm in the
morning my wife has hers but if if I'm
really feeling something I will stay up
until however late like until my body
crashes and then I'll sleep in the next
day and I never book stuff in the
morning my mornings are never booked I
do I have a routine that I usually go
through and part of that is checking in
my social media feeds and responding
people on YouTube and stuff that I do on
a daily basis but I never have a meeting
booked before noon they say because you
wants you to like just work on on other
stuff or is it because you just want to
have like your full routine morning
routine it's a combination of one I'm
not a morning person in general so if
I'm meeting people I'd rather meet them
later than in the morning and two it's a
buffer you know so as an example on
Tuesday was my book writing day I'm
writing a book and it was a 16-hour day
for me I started in the I started with
to YouTube Hangouts with Tim Schmoyer
who has a popular YouTube channel to
help entrepreneurs video entrepreneurs
and then I went in the full book writing
mode and was 12 straight hours of book
writing with only bathroom breaks my
wife came home and she's like have you
eaten like I haven't eaten and so she
like spoon-fed me no seriously like like
I don't have time I got I got to do this
you know so she's like taking a fork of
the sausage and putting it in my mouth
like like I'm a baby but I mean that's
awesome that I have a supportive wife
and I'm not doing that every day or the
worth I would you know obviously put a
strain on our relationship and and my
health but I was in the zone like if I
stepped out from
and then tried to step back into it
would take me like an hour two hours to
get back to where I was and I may not
even get to that mental zone of where I
was at that time and so when that
happens when I'm really feeling in the
zone on something then I try to stay
there as long as possible and that could
mean the next day I sleep in right I
could sleep in till 10:00 and I miss
answering some YouTube comments and I'll
push that to the next day because the
stuff that you create when you're in the
zone is way more important than the
stuff in your regular daily agenda so
I'll push meetings I'll push everything
off if I have that feeling that I'm in
known via and too many people cut that
off like you may have been in the zone
on something really feeling it and then
you're forced to leave it and then you
come back and it's not complete and you
don't know how to complete it and the
energy is gone and it's easy to trick
yourself like I'm really in the flow
answering these emails you know it's
like that's not what we're talking about
right like it's big picture ideas that's
really gonna catapult your business
forward that's that's what I'm talking
about and you know like don't lie to
yourself you know when something is
really important and you're feeling it
and so I'll push off like I'll forget to
eat I'll forget yeah you just go
everything right and I'll push through I
won't even realize that I'm tired right
because I'm just so I didn't realize
that was 12 straight hours without
looking up and doing anything else
me and my wife came home she has a
normal 9:00 to 5:00 job it's like wow
it's already 5:30 huh what where did it
go
I'm just locked in and so when I'm there
I try to stay there and I wish I could
say I'm locked in every day but I'm not
if you want to join the best life 30
challenge and get the free worksheets
click the link right here below me or if
you want more videos on how to optimize
your sleep check out the playlist right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there